how did it work this process of
radicalization because I'm sure that it
works with lots of things not just the
far-right but also you know Islamic
fundamentalism how do you go from a
normal young lad who's 1516 to entering
this organization
- then parroting Nick Griffin - then
saying awful things how does that
process work so in I've just written a
book plug sorry monster thorough making
and it's kind of like reports of
biographies sort of it's but it's
interlaced with you know analysis and
ideas and the argument I make in the
book is that I think there's two kinds
of people that join these organizations
there's principled fanatics and joiners
and a joiner is someone who's devoid of
any sort of ideology it's someone who's
kind of an outcast they're vulnerable
they don't have much going in their life
and they're looking for a community and
I think that works for lots of other
groups I'd say a lot of sjw's join us
but then a principled fanatic is
somebody I would say I'm probably a
principled fanatic because there was an
element of being a joiner you know I was
an outcast and bit weird and bit of a
nerd but I joined because I saw real
world problems you know I always say
extremism isn't created in a void you
don't just become something out of
nothing and when you're a principled
fanatic it's because you have principles
you see a real problem you see grooming
gangs or you see that immigration is too
high and nobody wants to talk about that
because it's racist and so you join
pretty much any anyone who's willing to
talk about it and I did and see ya
within a few years you end up just sort
of it's snowballs I suppose but there's
another argument I make which is the
three-pronged attack and that is I think
it's a process so it starts with
negligent politicians you know the
politicians it's inconvenient for them
to talk about certain issues they might
get dogpile if they do talk about it so
immigration multiculturalism leaving the
EU even they don't talk about these
issues because it's difficult but those
issues are very real for some groups of
people white working-class people in
particular and so then you look to the
media and you think well the media
should be that check on the politicians
right the media should be the ones
standing up
to the politicians but actually the
media the ones calling the working class
people racist and so the end you go out
on the street and when you got on the
street and you're shouting from the
rooftops it's like please do something
about these problems we care about and
then the far-left activists break your
window or something or smasher over the
head with a bike lock and so it's
backing people into a corner and no
matter whether you agree with the
concerns or the ideas that some sections
of the white working-class community
might have no matter whether you agree
with them or not politicians should
represent those people or at least talk
about those issues and because they're
not this this three-pronged attack this
process is backing people into a corner
and leaving them with nowhere to go and
most people just shut up and put the
head down and accept of this is life now
you know political correctness gone mad
and they you know they have
conversations in the kitchen at parties
you know in the under hushed tones about
you and that's crazy isn't it but then a
lot of people don't want to live like
that they don't have live in secrecy and
so they get really angry about it and
most of those lads end up joining the
far-right because there's no one else
talking about it
[Music]
you
[Music]